I have favored I have certainly was a
fan of Mad Magazine growing up and
especially the the mad comics the harvey
kurtzman ones before it became a
magazine or like you know i had the
little reprint digester those and i was
a kid and I didn't know what they were
the history or whatever but they were so
funny and weird and I i would say of
anything like those were my biggest sake
comedic influence just I've reread those
stories over and over again and in sort
of scour the background for all the
crazy background jokes and I you know I
think Animal House is a nearly perfect
movie just it has incredibly it's like
ninety-eight percent of its jokes are
successful you know what I mean it's a
perfectly Pleasant movie to watch and
with a lot of funny jokes my family is
not really that funny my family doesn't
really right I'm in fact my mother
always my advice to me as a child was
never put anything in writing which was
strange but now there's there's no one
who there's no you know kooky uncle who
inspired me